il ya cinquante ans c'était mai 68
le festival de cannes s'était sabordé
avait volontairement a interrompu tous
par signe de solidarité avec les grecs
qui avait en france cette année-là et au
même moment sortait aux etats-unis
l'affairé thomas crown un film qui était
devenu une légende et dont la musique
était signée par un français michel
legrand
le thème de ce film lui-même ne cesse de
bouger
c'est juliette armanet qu'il interprète
ce soir
[Applaudissements]
comme bien re que l'on jette dans le
vide d'un réseau et qui laisse derrière
elle des milliers de ronds dans l'eau
comme un manège de lui avec ses chevaux
des droits comme un anneau de saturne
romain lourd de carnaval comme le cheveu
de route que font sans cesse à les
hommes le voyage autour du monde
quand on est seul dans ce flou tu fais
tourner deux tons
tous les moulins de mon coeur
ce jour là près de la source
je sais ce que tu m'as tu
mais le définit sa cour
l'oiseau tomba de son nez et voilà que
sur le salon
non pas ses fans se déchaînent et je
suis les raisons sont mes doigts comme
un tambourin qui peut
les contres de la pelouse
comme les chansons qui mal
aussitôt qu'on les oublie
les feuilles de l'otan
rencontre les ciels - bleu et ton
absence l'automne la couleur de tai chi
comme pierre que longer pour vivre d'un
vaisseau qui laisse derrière elle des
milliers de ronds dans l'eau elle vend
des quatre saisons tu fais tourner de
toi tous les moulins ton coeur stimulent
chez hanwha rect c'est qu'au statut va
innover au monde
[Applaudissements]